i'm not sure how many uh times it has to
be said but the risk to children
from uh this disease for fatality is
nearly zero
i never hear anyone talk about the harms
of closing schools the harms are against
the children anyone who prioritizes
children
would open the school this is a level of
hysteria like this is something i feel
like i'm living in a kafka novel here
i mean i get thousands of emails a week
from all over the world they are stunned
at that we are willing
to just simply destroy our children out
of some bizarre notion that is
completely contrary to the science
fascinating interview last night on a
martha mccallum show that was senior
fellow
at stamford's hoover institution and
former chief of neuroradiology at
stanford medical center
all this as leaders debate at the state
and federal level reopening
our schools this fall states like
florida
are now seeing an uptick in cases
unprecedented surges
in some areas the sunshine state now has
more than 280 thousand confirmed cases
more than all but nine countries
worldwide florida senator marco rubio is
chairman of the intelligence committee
and joins us now with more good morning
senator thanks for being here so i'll
ask you the question we all of us as
parents
are asking each other we're asking the
leaders at the local state and federal
level
can our kids get back to school safely
will this happen
well i think it's pretty clear by now
that the people running our schools and
our states
are are not going to open up schools as
long as infection rates are at a certain
level so i think that puts the onus on
all of us whether you believe it's safe
or not
to do everything we can to bring the
infection rates under control
that that said i will tell you that i
hope as we make these decisions that it
undergoes a cost-benefit analysis
uh clearly there is uh the benefits of
closing schools are weighed against the
community spread that we're seeing
you know the outbreaks and and i
understand i mean it's not
inconsequential and it's a real threat
the costs are significant though imagine
if you're a single mother who has to be
at work every day at eight am not your
job depends on it
what do you do with your nine-year-old
if schools aren't open you're probably
dropping them off with the lady in the
neighborhood who takes care of every kid
in the neighborhood
and that's risky too not to mention the
children aren't learning and these
learning losses are very very
significant
so it has an economic impact it has a
learning impact it has long-term impact
that will be with us long after the
pandemic has passed
so we've got away the cost of the
benefits and and there will always be
risk as long as there's no immunity from
the from this virus so
um we're gonna have to do the best we
can and be flexible but at some point
schools really do need to open
but let's let's talk now because i mean
we're weeks away
senator and this is no longer big
picture you know we'll talk about it in
the fall
i mean the planning has to be in place
to safely get kids back in
and you go back to what you just heard
from the former chief
of neuroradiology at stanford medical
center talking about
the harm to children if we keep schools
closed he says nobody's talking about
that
yeah and that needs to be part of the
equation the harm is more than just
learning gains by the way i mean
a lot of the child abuse cases in this
country are identified
first and foremost to the front line in
schools when you see kids showing up
with bruises and other injuries
so there's a lot of things built into
this that are a real cost
and that's why i think every teacher who
has a condition or someone at home
should have the option of not being able
to not be forced to go into work and put
their lives in danger of that of their
loved ones
same with students who are in that
predicament so there has to be a
non-school option available to people
but i do believe we have to work extra
hard to be as flexible as we can
to figure out a way to get those who do
need to be in school
into a brick and mortar facility so they
can learn this is particularly important
for working families
and i think more affluent families this
is a big hassle but they can you know i
think they're going to figure it out the
ones who are going to be really impacted
are working families and low-income
families and and
who just don't have those options
available to them but what can we do
realistically i mean talk details you're
a senator in a state that is dealing
with
a spike in cases right now florida's a
mess i mean there's no doubt
you can put it up on the screen cases in
florida 282
435 that is more cases than all but nine
countries around the world
4 277 deaths you just heard the doctor
talking about the low
risk to children so he says get them
back into the classroom
so what details can you provide us about
doing that
how do you keep the teachers safe how do
you get them back into the into the
brick and mortar as you said
well a couple points the first is
florida's an enormous state we have 67
counties
and we have a number of counties that
find themselves in the situation you're
describing and then we have counties
that are not in that place and i think
those counties should move forward with
the ability to start school on time
second is i think we need to really go
and have a comprehensive understanding
of what the best practices are
for opening up the schools we we can
learn from the experience of
other countries that have done it but
also from daycare centers
many of whom have been open the entire
time and and we haven't you know we
have been able to do so relatively
safely i think we have to go into it
with the assumption by the way
that you're never going to be 100 here
as long as this virus is spread from
person to person we have to mitigate
risk
but we cannot eliminate it and so i
think it's a combination of technology a
combination of scheduling of spacing of
protective equipment
best practices distancing and other
things in some parts
places where you can you can teach
outdoors which we know is a safer
setting
i i don't think that there has been
established sort of this this
best practices criteria for places that
do need to open
um and then i think every county is
going to have to make a decision based
on their local conditions
and and what that implies but but the
one thing i'd love to see is some sort
of matrix of best practices that don't
make the risk
zero but that substantially lower the
risk for both the teachers
and for the students who can take it
back home and infect parents and
grandparents it's important to point out
that every parent wants to ensure the
safety of their child but every
parent is concerned about the future of
their child as well and their education
and they want to see a priority
on children in this country this
georgetown professor put out a
fascinating piece in the wall street
journal talking about young people
sacrificed their lives
they stayed home to protect somebody
like him in a high-risk category
he said now it's my obligation as a
teacher to get back on campus this fall
he writes why i'll be on campus for me
missing one year in the classroom is not
much of a sacrifice
but my undergraduate students have only
four years in college
and my law students only three in law
school i have clear memories of how
personally
meaningful and fleeting those years are
those are the conversations we want to
hear we know that there's risks
but we do want to get the sense of
urgency that these teachers
superintendents and then of course the
mayors and the
and the governors of these states are
placing urgency on this and prioritizing
kids and prioritizing education final
thought center
yeah absolutely so i think that's the
part of the costs that are not being
taken into account the cost of not
reopening look people are going to work
every day
they're going to work at the grocery
store they're going to work at walgreens
walmart cvs
they're picking up garbage they're
police and fire they're the janitors at
hospitals
people are going to work every day and
we're having to protect them some of
those similar
expectations should be placed on those
in the education system we have to
figure out a way to get back into school
maybe we start a little later maybe
you're flexible about the scheduling but
it has to happen because again
the biggest losers here in this decision
making is going to be lower income and
working families
who do not have those options available
to them to simply
leave their kids at home and and not
have a school that is open and so i do
hope that we take it more seriously
it's not the sort of decisions that
should be made cavalierly on the basis
of sort of some of the pressure that
people are getting in in the public
square
i want to finish off by asking about you
senator marco
rubio ted cruz as well congressman chris
smith
and the ambassador for religious freedom
sam brownback
you've been targeted now by china with
sanctions
because you've been critical of the
country's actions toward minority groups
and people of
faith what is happening there and can
you give us an update on the situation
senator
yeah it's pretty simple i mean china is
a totalitarian regime that oppresses its
own people that is jailing
over a million uh uyghur muslims and
trying to
change their identity strip them of
their cultural identity their religious
identity their names
they call it re-education camps there in
many cases these are not
these are actually labor force labor
camps it's an outrage
and i'll continue to speak out on it i
had no intention of traveling to china
anytime
soon anyway i didn't think they were
going to walk all out to welcome that
but it shows me
i'm actually proud of it you know
honestly i didn't look for it but i'm
proud of that band because it shows
we're on the right side
any time a totalitarian and evil regime
is against you
you know you're on the right side all
right senator marco rubio from florida
we always appreciate getting on the show
thanks for your time this morning
thank you